[Music]
in teachers care news submitted by baby
tech guys so cute he's got the big
eyeballs the mouth the ocean of mouth is
the best it makes me smile
it makes me so angry how cute he is cuz
it's so [ __ ] perfect [ __ ] love
them
I call them my baby snowman you know
that's like a white little head with
like raisin eyes you'll be a subset when
he gets teeth I'm like meh [ __ ] those
things I'm a puck amount teddy bear legs
right now I know West Virginia teachers
packed lunches for their students before
going on strike oh that's sweet that's
really sweet so they want to poison the
kids before they leave oh my god what's
going on no need for the kids to suffer
they're always like makes assumptions
and guesses I don't know what are they
striking for what is going on for higher
wages and better benefits that it's a
good call they're gonna fight to marry
their cousin oh my God we're out
Virginia West Virginia West Virginia
with Esther you here to say with you is
will you leave my brother husband alone
I love people how dare you I do agree
though one of the biggest deterrence for
me not to become a teacher was the fact
that I couldn't make a living wage off
yeah it was the biggest biggest attorney
I have always loved education you guys
know I always talk about the [ __ ] how
much I think it's [ __ ] important but
the craziest thing is like keep on
giving these teachers more
responsibilities but they don't give
them more pain I'm glad the
superintendent's are getting way more
pay though oh yeah I saw that video I
know this ballin out and [ __ ] dude
teachers have to work side jobs during
the summer yeah we don't get paid in the
summer yeah what I'm saying is - it's
like you should at least pay them like
the same amount that other state workers
get paid you mean you can't they can't
live off a 35 K here who the [ __ ] you
could work get in and out and get more
money than that how did this happen how
did teachers get shafted so hard my
his mom makes six figures as a junior
high teacher private or public
lower-income neighborhood
how the [ __ ] what she she has tenure oh
that's why she's been there for a long
time 18 20 years she's ancient she's
like yeah that's true yeah I think up
the star for like 10-15 years before you
make them yeah so the entry pay is like
thirty thousand or maybe cuz it's LA oh
my god
it's about like there I don't know what
it is but I heard that the more
dangerous you go the more pity the more
pay they give you cuz nobody wants to go
there
yeah jeez that's crazy yeah so for the
teachers in West Virginia they just feel
it's it's not fair the fact that
surrounding states for public school
teachers they make anywhere from 5,000
to 20,000 more than teachers in West
Virginia so that's why they're organized
this protest in all 55 counties of West
Virginia so that's about 20,000
classroom teachers that are involved in
this whole thing in West Virginia almost
one in four children are in poverty so
they a lot of these kids their meal of
the day comes from school and that's why
these teachers they organize and they
set out these like lunch drives like
food drives probably paid for that [ __ ]
out of their own pockets too yeah and a
lot of it was donated so by my
organizations and so they initially
thought that they were only gonna be
protesting for two days but ended up
going for a week and so they started
setting up all these other locations to
have parents come and pick up food for
their kids for example here like this
like makeshift ation where i can just
come and pick up food it's really sweet
the fact that the teachers cared so much
where they're like you know what we need
to do this for ourselves but not at the
expense of our students we got to figure
out a better way to fund the public
schools because the way it works is the
city limits is basically like relying on
homeowners and and the taxes is a
property tax to pot right so if there's
a lot of renters in that area or if it's
low income and the low income people
aren't paying their mortgage or paying
whatever they're also not paying the
taxes and in turn like that's where the
kids need the most education you know
like they need you most help because
they're not going to have
poor mobility they're not going to be
able to probably leave that social
status or class like they're not gonna
be able to [ __ ] get better that's
what all the bother communities that
have the hella good schools because the
property tax is so high but then like
the more like lower-class communities
there's not that much property time yes
but what they were doing in my area
was they were busing kids like from
different schools so like kids in my
area were able to go to torrents or like
other neighborhoods but you already had
to be a good kid like they're not gonna
send the bad kids there you know free
lunch I just get so jealous I used to
get free lunch in school I don't know
why mommy it's a Vietnamese way you
[ __ ] dick the system and whatever you
get for lunch and free lunch was so
tight dude did you get though the blue
one for the morning and in the yellow
yeah yeah with a date on the ticket we
do we get breakfast I don't remember any
breakfast but I never made it to
breakfast I love brother we like the
little breakfast burrito with the liquid
cheese I don't like the little sausage
crumbles I love school food so much cuz
my those the food at home sucked ass I
couldn't wait to get that stale ass
bread you know what I found out so like
you know how the school lunch food was
super like unhealthy
yeah like hella fat hella like nastier
yeah I heard that's because um they
wanted kids to eat a lot of calories
because a lot of the kids that was their
only meal yeah I was like what the [ __ ]
I didn't even know that show I was I
will say this though thank you for those
[ __ ] delicious little pies that were
in the plastic I call them hood pies I
don't know what I don't know what the
name your price moon pies no no no no
it's like cutlet glazed in sugar
Oh wax bean run yeah
liquor store has they're like rock hard
but once you break into them it's
actually soft and get up what is this
hope I got you one depart memory okay if
you saw one you know what's up dude it
looks like it's covered in juice like a
hardened juice yeah I don't know maybe
if I see you know what they should do
they should make a restaurant of
elementary school food yeah I want to go
back to elementary school just like we
eat that [ __ ] the corn that's on top
look at sloppy joes did you guys ever
have a taco pocket
cuz I cannot what is that the taco boat
no I think a hot pocket pitaka meat
inside yeah and I've been searching for
it and it has to come yeah and it's
gonna be bombed though yep and genius no
it can't be mom asked me it's like
shitty school food quality I also want
to make a profit so it's like [ __ ]
jackass patties with the weird colour
and in the milk in the bag do you guys
get that no you know the candy and the
balloons
I wanted the bag okay you know what
sucks although I'm allergic to milk so I
had to pay for the old every video it's
a [ __ ] different thing so are you or
not
I'm not lactose that's me today other
days it's you guys I'm that person you
know you could either get regular milk
or chocolate milk right and I've been in
strawberry milk or orange juice
what's extra the Sonny Dee's dog yeah
Sunny D when they came out with the
different flavors because I thought that
your even say orange milk because you
were like listing it like like regular
milk chocolate strawberry I never got no
milk in bags though I didn't know it was
no I didn't know that it was a thing
that free lunch kids actually got picked
on or like it was cuz they were poor I
love my free lunch I never got the girl
you know who got picked on the Asian
kids that brought [ __ ] lunch does
smell bad that's all you gotta throw
that [ __ ] away before school starts most
of the kids were [ __ ] poor so it's
like how you're gonna make fun of the
kids with the free lunch that's the
majority yeah you're gonna make fun of
the kids where your moms love you and
[ __ ] I get the good food and you get
your shitty ass mottling mom's food and
your parents in art school I say over
half the kids had free lunch so it's
they were the majority so like for me
like we didn't make a lot of money but I
think my parents had too much pride to
apply however I do not we qualified for
that [ __ ] so it's like why the [ __ ] not
you know I mean I'm gonna be a pay for a
[ __ ] sandwich you're [ __ ] oh they
made you pay huh your parents didn't pay
they made you pick yeah really don't
even make they give you money I worked
up a parent store so I had I had money
to pay for it yeah I mean and so like
you know my parents would give me quota
: I might say what the [ __ ] I remember
the meals like a dollar seventy-five
after a while no it was 65
for us back then yeah way back in the
day I remember one time I paid with
because I just needed a dime but then I
have like 10 cents like buttom vessels
and I ended up paying in and she
accepted only oh poor Mexican girl
30 milk in bags remember when they used
to give you grapes in [ __ ] napkins
great what no I don't know that just to
walk by the cafeteria where they closed
the door there's a that glass with the
wire yeah and you see the kid I don't
want by looking I'm like she's making
magic again man is daily magic
[Music]